welcome to the thankful Thursday I
believe is important to thank the people
who've had an impact on your business on
your life because you can't do this
thing alone running the business it's a
hard heart endeavor to launch into and
it's nice just to say thank you to the
people who helped you along the way so
today i want to thank Jeff Walker now
Jeff is an internet marketer who have
actually never met but he's an internet
marketer he's got a great YouTube
channel that I recently subscribed to
and Jeff is first of all very authentic
very honest very approachable in his
videos and it's nice because you see so
many internet marketers and you think
this guy's a scanner or this guy's going
to rip me off and there's a humbleness
and there's a openness about Jeff that I
really appreciate and so I love watching
his videos and I've seen started
watching every video that they came out
with he recently came up with a video
that was interesting and he talked about
starting your morning routine by being
grateful and thinking about a couple
things that you're grateful for and just
writing them down or thinking about them
and starting your day with that because
it sets you up for positive vibe so I
thought hey you know what I'm always
trying to tweak my routine try to make
it as optimized for health and happiness
in business awesomeness as much as
possible so i thought i would try it
every morning I have this little notepad
that I keep next to me on the bed and
when I wake up I will write down three
things that I'm grateful for so you just
starts like this I'll say the date and
then i'll i will write i'm grateful for
and then list three things and some of
them are are big things obviously things
that might come to mind immediately like
your family and friends and some of them
are things that maybe a little more more
hidden you know like the internet i'm
grateful for the internet and its
existence because it's helping me a lot
so here are some examples so two days
ago i wrote i'm grateful for my health
my business and all the people i get to
help and inspire yesterday i wrote
ungrateful for hayden is my son Jeffrey
and Stephanie who are my niece and
nephew I'm grateful for pancakes
and I'm grateful for the condo that I
get to live in it's a nice condo and
then today this morning I woke up
writing I'm grateful for my parents my
education and my confidence and optimism
and so literally it takes me 30 seconds
I get up the first thing I think about
is what am i grateful for I write three
things down and I find it it just sets
me up for a positive feel good kind of
day gets me in the zone a little bit
more and if you can carry that gratitude
and positive energy forward into your
business day it's it yields positive
results so Jeff I wanted to thank you
for that awesome strategy I know I've
never met you but I'm making this video
tribute for you because you're awesome
it's really helped me and for those of
you watching take time to you could try
this strategy out every morning but also
take time today to think somebody was at
an impact on your business on your life
who gives you motivation that helps you
believe in yourself it'll make you feel
great and I make they'll feel great and
spreading the good business karma that
will help your company go forward
believe for those are watching like the
video you can subscribe to the channel
see more just like it thank you so much
I'll see you soon hi every kill English
here with mermaid junkie TV are you on
Evans newsletter subscription if not you
should be I read every single one and
you should too ciao
you